cette année le grand départ de paris
nice et lens de bois d'arcy une
logistique qui entraîne des
perturbations de circulation dès le
samedi 4 mars
on a des arrêtés d'interdiction de
stationnement qui vont commencer déjà
sur les parkings à partir de jeudi soir
et qui vont s'étaler tout le week-end
et puis après un arrêté de circulation
qui va être assez importants sur les
principaux axes de circulation de bois
d'arcy à savoir l'avenue jean jaurès
la rupture peau la rue barbusse et la
rue paul vaillant couturier avec un
arrêt total de la circulation dimanche
toute la journée quasiment tous les
jours après bois d'arcy le peloton se
dirige vers saint quentin en yvelines
sept communes sont traversées à deux
reprises de montigny le bretonneux à
magny les hameaux d'abord puis le nord
de l'agglomération plaisir à les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux et des
coupures totales ou partielles sont
prévues entre 12h et 17h du côté
transports en commun la gare routière
avenue des prêts et fermé 6 lignes tibus
voient leur parcours modifié notamment
la 415 à part du ministre denis jusqu'au
théoriquement bois d'arcy et la fra
terminus à montigny-le-bretonneux
le plus gros impact et sur la ligne 4
114 qui est coupé en deux il y aura un
bus qui partira de saint quentin pour
aller jusqu'au lycée descartes et de
l'autre côté un bus qui fera la gare de
trappes disco oman et le conseil c'est
de préparer son trajet en amont via le
site internet de ski bus vous avez les
horaires et les arrêts non desservis
pas à cause de cette manifestation dix à
quinze mille personnes sont attendues
dimanche vers 16h45 le premier maillot
jaune de ce paris nice sera connu l'an
dernier c'était l'australien michael
matthews qui l'endossé